[Music]  renew Europe or ar e is a new group in  the European Parliament its priorities  are democracy sustainability and  prosperity renew europe replaces the  alliance for liberals and democrats in  europe  our group is group in the center of the  European Parliament strongly citizens  oriented defending values as freedom  individual rights prosperity in Europe  sustainability in Europe and the  balanced economic and social development  with 108 MEP s re is the third political  force in the European Parliament  it has members from 22 in new countries  and unites the Alliance of liberals and  Democrats for Europe and the European  Democratic Party our core values are  related to democracy rule of law  individual rights and freedom but also  European solutions to European problem  and we are also against any liberalism  or any division in Europe